Gerard Butler's latest movie London has
fallen hits theaters Friday but that's
not the only reason he's making
headlines this week the Scottish star
also joined Instagram it's definitely a
steep learning curve I am so not a
social media guy Butler got candid with
ET at the film's premiere on Tuesday
where he hilariously revealed what kind
of photos we can look forward to on his
account lunch what movies I'm going to
see what I'm thinking about just may be
pretty colors in the sky yeah I mean
that shirtless selfie oh and then
shortly selfies yeah and then me when
I'm at it I'm sure in the
action-thriller Butler reprises his role
as Mike banning a Secret Service agent
who's expecting a child there's no small
thing being a godmother I mean I didn't
take your asking lightly oh I know
Butler isn't a father in real life but
still we had to know hypothetically his
top pick for a celebrity godparents
someday I think Hilary Swank would be a
great because she's just a beautiful
elegant royal lady but I but I'm to a
basset actually pretty great she's
pretty awesome to be honest